razer pages can make it even simpler to
create web apps using net core brugen
patel is an experienced instructor and
he will teach you how to create web apps
using.net core and razer pages
[Music]
hi guys and welcome to dot net mastery
my name is broken and in this course we
will explore the basic foundation of
dotnet code web applications with razer
pages
we will be using dot net 6 and visual
studio 2022 for this short course
dot net core has been a buzzword for a
while and most of the new development in
dot net is built on.net core and the
current version is dot net six
dot net core comes with great features
and advantages as compared to the
previous versions of dot net
but for starters let's take a brief
overview at topics we will cover in this
course
whenever we learn any programming
language the first thing is basic
foundation
so we will start with the fundamentals
of asp.net core application
then we will take a look at what is new
or what are the changes in dotnet 6 as
compared to the previous version
once we have a solid foundation in.net
core files and folder structure then we
will take a look at entity framework
core that is what we will be using to
interact or create our database project
using entity framework core and dot net
core we will perform crud operations on
a particular model
when we do that we will understand the
client side and server side validations
in dot net core and we will display
alerts using temp data
that will give you a good foundation in
dot net core
but the main thing that i will also
include is error solving
i will display you common errors and how
to resolve them that way you will gain
more confidence in what you will learn
lastly the application that we will
build we will deploy that to azure along
with the sql server
so with all of that you will have a good
starting foundation in dotnet core using
razer pages
in this video let's take a look at what
we will build in this course
from the url here you can see that the
application is live on azure we will
host our application on azure along with
sql server
then in the top navigation we have a
home page and a categories page
if you click on categories we do not
have any categories right now
so we can first click on create a
category button
and on this page if you click the create
button without populating any fields we
get error messages
these are client-side validations right
out of the box
we also have a button to go back to the
list
then if we go back on create page and if
we populate the details in the category
with just the name
we still have validation with display
order
we also have a custom validation that if
name and display order are same then we
will also display a custom error message
the error that you see this time is a
server-side validation
then if we have values that passes all
the validation and if we hit the create
button
we have nice alert to display the
confirmation we will be using toaster.js
for these alerts
then we have all the categories that we
will be displaying in the table here we
can edit them and once we update them we
again have our alerts confirmation
lastly we also have the delete
functionality with the alerts
and then for the theme that we are using
for styling we are using boots watch
theme and we will deploy our application
to azure
so you can see there are quite a few
things to learn in this small project
let's get started with all of them from
the next video
let's take a look at all the tools that
we will use in this course
we will be using dotnet 6 for our
application
so make sure to install the latest
version of dotnet6
for the ide we will be using visual
studio
the version that i will be using is
visual studio 2022
there are lots of advanced features in
2022 as compared to 2019
so you can always install the free
version of visual studio 2022
for our database we will be using sql
server
so first you will have to install sql
server and then you should install ssms
which is sql server management studio
if you have older version of ssms that's
completely okay
as long as you're able to connect to sql
server on your local machine we will be
using that connection string and
everything will work
so once you install all three of these
softwares let's continue from the next
video
in this video i want to walk you through
the journey of net core
dot net core is probably the biggest
change that the dot net language has
encountered
in 2002 microsoft introduced web forms
which was a revolution at that time
webforms has its drawbacks and there was
a need to overcome all of them
because of that the.net team came up
with a new architecture which was dotnet
mvc
now even though i love mvc and i have
built many applications in mvc it had
its flaws
like it was created on top of the
components for web forms
because of that it was tied to iis and
ultimately windows operating system
but with the evolution of web
development microsoft had to keep up
with the changing technology
finally in june of 2016 microsoft
released asp.net core and it was the
first version
now.net core is built on top of the
new.net core framework it is completely
rewritten and it is a cross-platform
version hence it is not tied with
windows
also.net core was built with cloud in
mind
so it is extremely robust with that
then in august of 2018 microsoft
released.net core 2 and the team has
been active with releasing new versions
there was a big change from dotnet 2.1
to 2.2 because we had to update quite a
few class libraries and there were few
challenges
but since then dot net core team has
been releasing new versions with 3 3.1
and net 5 which was released in november
of 2020
after that there is dotnet 6 which will
be released in november of 2021
we will be using the preview version but
whatever we learn will be the same once
dotnet 6 is released
so this is a small overview of all
the.net frameworks and their evolution
that being said why should one use dot
net core as compared to the classic.net
dot net core comes with many advantages
first one is asp.net core is fast and
open source
if you compare that to the
traditional.net applications that have
been quite a few benchmarks and it is
very fast when you compare that to web
forms or even dotnet mvc
dotnet core is also cross-platform
the classic.net was tied to iis and
windows
but since the net core is rewritten it
has removed that dependency with net
core
we also have a built-in support for
dependency injection which saves a lot
of time and it is extremely helpful
once you get used with using dependency
injection you cannot imagine your
application without that
with any programming language it is
critical that the new updates are the
new version that are released they
should be easily upgradable and that is
one of the feature with net core
when a new version is released updating
to that new version does not have
groundbreaking changes
because of that you can always keep up
with the new
versions dot net code is also cloud
friendly
when the dot net core was being written
cloud architecture was kept in mind and
because of that it is completely
compatible with all of the cloud
components
and lastly when it comes to performance
dot net core exceeds all of the previous
versions and even the new versions in
dot net core that are being released
they supersede the previous version
the code actually gets more optimized
that results into improved performance
the asp.net core compiler will
eventually optimize the entire code
whenever the code is recomposed using
the.net core framework
dot net core's actual performance is
multiple times than any of the
frameworks previous implementation
because of that it is clear that
microsoft has a long-term plan with dot
net code technology
so with that brief overview let's
continue our learning in the next video
in this video before we take a look at
the other files i will introduce you to
a new concept which is dependency
injection
asp.net core implements a simple
built-in dependency injection
container dependency injection is an
integral part of the asp.net core
architecture
dot net core injects objects of
dependency classes through constructor
by using the built-in ioc container
before i show you what advantages
dependency injection brings
let's see a scenario where there is no
dependency injection
in a typical application let's say we
have three pages right now and we have
some common functionality that we want
to use across all the three pages
like let's say we want to send emails
and we want to access our database in
all the three pages that we have now
let's imagine that on these three pages
we need to access the database first
so what we will do is we will create the
object for database classes on all the
three pages we will have to open that
connection we will have to do the
database operation and then we will have
to close the connection in all the
places
to do the same and create object for
email implementation that we have in all
the three pages so you can see this is
lot of duplicate code
on top of that what happens in future if
you change the implementation of how you
access the database or email
based on the current configuration you
might have to make that change in all of
the three pages
which is a big mess because right now
it's three pages down the line it could
be 30 or 300 pages
another issue here is that on each page
you will deal with creating the object
managing them as well as disposing them
and that will be a time consuming effort
when we have to do that in all the pages
so that being said what is a solution to
avoid all of this and get an optimal
architecture
the answer to all of that is dependency
injection
first let me show how the scenario would
look like again we will have the three
pages and we will have email and
database functionality
these are the common things that we had
before as well
but now we will have something special
which is dependency injection container
so as you can see we have got our
dependency injection container that will
have an eye email and an itp interface
and its implementation
so inside our container we have the
implementation of the i email interface
and the itb interface
when any page will need access to these
functionalities it will just ask the
dependency injection container to create
an object of this functionality
and directly give page an object to use
so inside the page we will actually be
using an interface and then dependency
injection does all its magic of passing
the object when the website needs it
that way we do not have to deal with
creating the object disposing or
managing that object inside our pages
our pages will look very clean with just
the interface
all the instance and implementation will
be done by dependency injection
container
now in future if you want to change or
replace the email class you do not have
to make any changes in the pages
all you have to do is just change the
implementation inside the email class
and since we are registering that in the
container
next time when we build the project it
will take the new implementation
so you can see we only have to change in
one place now
that is one of the main advantage that
comes with dependency injection
now in order to use dependency injection
you can use many third-party tools
but with dot net core we have a built-in
dependency injection container and that
has its own advantages
so i hope with that you have a short
overview of how dependency injection is
helpful
first thing that we have to do is we
need to create a new project
so i have opened up visual studio 2022
which will be the editor for this course
here on the left hand side i have my
previous projects and on the right hand
side we have the options to get started
we will click on create a new project
and we have lots of templates that are
available
we want to create a web application so
we can select that
and we want the web app with razer pages
so that is the first option that is
being selected but if the first option
in your case is something different
scroll down and look for asp.net core
web app
it should only be web app and not the
web app with models view and controller
that you see down here we are working
with only razer page application
so select that and we will hit the next
button
next thing that we can give our project
is a meaningful name we will call that
as abby
now here you notice there is a project
name and a solution name
a solution can have multiple project
let's say we are working on abbey web
project so we can call that abbey web
and then we can just change the solution
to be abbey
so all the projects that are related to
abby will be inside the same solution
next let me change the location to where
i want to save the project and we will
hit the next button
here we will get some more options on
what is the net framework that we want
to use
i will select.net 6 here and next we
have the authentication type
now if we want we can select the
pre-built templates that are available
with authentication but we want to start
from scratch we will select none here
i do not want any docker
and let's hit the create button
that will create our project and we will
see all the files and folder structures
on the left hand side inside the window
of solution explorer in visual studio
now by chance if you close the window do
not panic
you can reload that by going to views
and the first one here is solution
explorer
so now that our project is created let's
continue in the next video
now that the project has been created
you can see there are quite a few files
and folder structure on the right hand
side
if you expand the pages folder that will
display all the pages in our application
before i dive into all the files and
folder here let me run the application
by clicking on this play icon with the
project name which is appy web
that will build your project and it will
open up the browser with our website
so perfect on the default page here you
can see in the navigation we have home
and privacy page
on the home page we have a welcome text
and a link that takes us to the.net core
website
let's go back to our application and
inside the pages folder we have a page
with the name of index.cshd
this is the home page of our application
you can see we have the same welcome
text here and paragraph that is
displaying inside the default page
now do not worry about the linking
routing files and folders or this page
model or anything on top right here
we will walk through all of them as we
proceed with the course
but before anything i want to walk you
through one example
inside the welcome here let's see if you
change some text here save this file and
go back
you do not see that change right here
to see that you will have to refresh the
page and then you see that change
but after that if you make any change in
the files here and if you save it go
back you can see we do not have to
refresh
let me show that once again
so if i make a change and as soon as i
save it you will see the website reloads
and display the change
that is because with dot net 6 we have
something called as hot reload
and that is a great functionality
because now if you are designing
something you make change it is
automatically reflected in the view
so if this feature is not enabled you
can see the red icon here if you take
your mouse there it displays hot reload
you click on the arrow icon and make
sure hot reload on file save is enabled
as long as that is enabled only first
time you will have to refresh the
application
after that if you save the changes it
will automatically reload the page
and again this feature has been added to
dotnet 6
so if you are working with previous
version this will not work
for previous versions what you have to
do is if you right click on the project
select manage nuget packages
inside the browse tab we had to install
a new get package
so if i search for runtime compilation
we have a package for
microsoft.asp.netcode.mvc.razer.runtime
compilation
we had to install this package and once
you install that package we had to make
a change inside the program.ces class
file
so once that package has been installed
if you go to program.ces class file
where we are adding the razer pages here
we also had to add the razer runtime
compilation
now do not worry about this file i will
explain everything here but if you are
working with a version before.netfi
this is the change that was needed
now even though i recorded this codes in
dot net 6 when i was recording this
feature was not available
so in the later videos on the razer
pages i will be adding the ad raiser
runtime compilation
but you do not have to do that because
now we have hot reload and that takes
care of the runtime compilation
so that being said let me close all the
tabs here
let's not save anything and let's
analyze all the files and folder
structure in our project
i just wanted to give you a quick sneak
peek on how to reload
this video i want to give you a brief
overview of razer pages
razer pages have been introduced in
asp.net core from the version 2.0
razer pages is a new feature of asp.net
core that makes coding page focused
scenarios easier and more productive
in mvc we have models views and
controllers but inside razer pages we
have page and page model
so everything for that page is isolated
and condensed in one single location
that being said razer pages is not just
for simple scenarios
everything that you can do with mvc you
can do by using razer pages like routing
models action result tag helpers and so
on that is just a brief overview about
razer pages but we will explore
everything with razer pages in the
future videos
now that our application has been
created let's take a look at the first
file which will be the project file
project file you won't be able to see
that directly inside the files here you
will have to right click and we have
edit project file
when we click here you will see few
options that are configured
the first one here is the property group
and that denotes what is the net
framework that we are using
we are using dotnet 6 here and it is
displayed there
next what we have is the item group
item group will have all of the nuget
packages that we will be adding in our
course
right now we just added the razer
runtime compilation when we created the
project
but in future we will be adding more
packages for using sql server entity
framework core and much more
once we add that a new entry will be
made inside the item group
so that looks good for our project file
with that let's continue in the next
video
file that we want to take a look is
inside the properties folder we have
launch settings.json
this is the file that configures how the
application will be run and you can see
there are multiple profiles that are
added by default
we have an iis settings on the top which
says that if you are using iis express
to run the application your application
url will be this and the ssl port will
be 44317
if we expand the profiles here we have
two profile appy web and iis express
these are the same profiles that you can
see if you hover on the down arrow icon
right here
we have abby web and iis express
in order to run the website we can just
hit this play button after selecting the
profile
if we select iis express here and run
our website it will launch the default
application
inside the window directly with the
44317
port number
great you can see that is working
now if we stop this and change our
profile to appy web let's expand that
you can see here it is command name
which is project dot net run messages
and we have application url
so this will run our application from
command prompt
and from that command prompt it launches
the browser
this time it is running on port 5001
so these are two different ways of
running the.net core application
inside the profiles we can have
environment variable and other
configuration
these are just two ways to run your
application and we can modify them
inside the launch settings.json
the next thing that we have here is www
root folder and in there we have css js
and lib folders
www root folder will be the root
directory of your application
that will be the directory that contains
all of your static files
so if you have css javascript images pdf
files libraries all of them will go
inside the www root folder
inside this www root folder there will
not be any code behind file with the
c-sharp code
it will only have static files that will
be used from the pages
so make sure whenever you add any static
files it will go inside this www
root folder
next what we have here is the pages
folder and that contains all the coding
pages that are there in the application
we will come back to that in the
upcoming video but the last file that i
want to discuss in this video is the
appsettings.json file
now what happens is in an application
you are using many third-party apis and
then you have to store some secrets
you can also have connection strings
that connects to the database and so on
so all of those secret keys or
connection that you have you will add
them inside this
appsettings.json file
as the name suggests it is a json file
which will have key value pairs
if you expand this you will notice that
is appsettings.development.json
so you can have different app settings
for different environment
for production you will have
appsettings.production.json
and so on
then based on the environment variable
it will automatically configure and use
that particular app settings file
this is very helpful because development
can have a different connection string
to database as compared to preview
production or staging
so it is already built in and we will be
adding our connection string in this
file in the upcoming videos
so with that we have a brief overview of
all the files other than the pages
folder and program.cs
let's continue in the next video
next we have program.cs
this is the file that will be
responsible for running the application
once we open program.cs you can see we
have a variable builder
where the
webapplication.createbuilder is passed
with the built-in arguments
when you run with the dotnet command you
can pass custom arguments here if you
want
with that it will configure the
application and it will create the web
application builder object
now in the previous video we saw that we
can use dependency injection with dotnet
core
when we want to register anything with
our dependency injection container we
will be doing that right here
so let's say if we want to register our
database or email or anything else
we will have to do that between the
builder and before we call build on that
builder object
so right here we are just adding one
service to the container
which is builder dot services dot ad
raiser pages we are adding the razer
pages to our container because we are
building a website here with razer pages
so we have to add that
if you were using mvc then this would be
add controllers with views
now in the future videos when we
configure database in our project and we
add that to dependency injection we will
be adding a new service here in our
container or db context
if you are working with any version
prior to dotnet 6 or even some of the
initial preview versions of net 6
then this file was divided into a
separate startup.cs class file
and the services that we add to
container were inside a method configure
services and everything from line 9
onwards was inside a configure method
so what we have on the top is we will be
adding services to our container
then we need to configure request
pipeline and that pipeline will be
configured from the highlighted section
you might be wondering what is this
pipeline
the pipeline specifies how application
should respond to a web request
when your application receives a request
from the browser the request goes back
and forth through the pipeline
let me switch to the presentation here
we have different browsers here and then
we have a pipeline
the pipeline specifies how application
should respond to a request that is
received
when your application receives a request
from the browser the request goes
through the pipeline
in the pipeline you can add items that
you want
pipeline is made up of different
middlewares eraser pages is a type of
middleware itself
so if we want to build our website to be
built with razer pages we will have to
add the map razer pages to our
middleware
other example could be authentication
middleware authorization middleware and
so on
what exactly happens is when your
request will go through each of the
middleware it gets modified by them and
eventually it is passed to the next
middleware
if that is the last middleware in the
pipeline the response is returned back
to the server
let's take a look at the few middlewares
that we have in our application
let me switch back to the code here and
you can see in the pipeline first we are
checking if it is development or not in
the environment
if it is then we are adding the use
developer exception page that will show
you user friendly exceptions so that you
can debug and solve them but if it is
not development then we are just
redirecting them to an error page
the next middleware is https redirection
and then we have a middleware to use our
static files that are defined in www
root folder
we also have a routing middleware and we
have authorization middleware
when we add authentication to our
project we will have to add a new
middleware inside the program.cs as well
then we have app.map razer pages
this will configure the routing of razer
pages and how the mapping will work in
the application
based on this routing it will be able to
map the url request to the corresponding
pages inside our pages folder
then you should always keep in mind that
order of pipeline is extremely important
the way you write middlewares in the
pipeline that is exactly how the request
will be passed
so first routing will be done then it
checks for authorization and so on
so in this scenario if you want to use
authentication to your pipeline we have
a middleware which is app.use
authentication
but if you do this then it won't work
because authentication middleware should
always come before you authorize a user
because you only authorize a user that
is authenticated
that is the basic fundamentals of
authentication and authorization
so if you place the pipeline in some
different order that will break things
so with that brief overview of
program.cs class file let's continue
in the next video
one of the top level considerations for
the developer of a server-side web
application framework is how to match
the urls to the resources on the server
so that the correct one processes that
request
the most straightforward approach is
that you map the url to the physical
files on the disk and this approach has
been implemented by the asp.net team for
razer page framework
so the routing in asp.net razer pages
maps urls to the physical file on the
disk
now there are some rules on how razer
page framework matches the urls to the
files and how it can be customized to
give different results if needed the
first rule is that razer pages needs a
root folder
by default the folder has been named
pages and its location is inside the
root folder of the web application
also in that folder we will have a
default document which will be
index.cshtml
so let's go back to our application and
see this in action
so the root folder is the pages folder
that you can see here and if we expand
that we have index.cshtml
let me run the application here and see
what happens
inside here we are navigated to the home
page
the home page that loads here is the
default index.cshtml
inside the pages folder
if we click on privacy here you can see
the url changes to privacy
and that page is present directly inside
the pages folder
so the mapping of the url is directly
with the location inside the pages
folder now if we stop the application
and let's say we add a new folder here i
will call that as test
and let me move privacy inside test
let's click ok here and let's run the
application one more time
this time if you click on privacy
nothing happens
the reason is the url that has been
configured inside the master page which
is underscored layout let me show that
here the asp page is defined that you
have to look for a page which is privacy
directly inside the folder
but that does not exist because now we
have moved that to attached folder
so if we go back in order to navigate to
the new location it is simple
we just need to find out the exact path
from the pages folder
so inside pages we have a folder of test
inside there we have privacy
if we press enter you can see it loads
the privacy page correctly
so you can see routing has direct
mapping on how the files are exactly
stored inside the pages folder
let me stop the application
close everything and let me move the
privacy page
back to the pages folder
i will also delete the test folder that
we added
let's go back to our presentation and
here i have given some examples of how
the mapping works
so if the url is just www.domain.com
it will map to the pages folder and the
default page index.cshtml
if the url is domain.com forward slash
index then it will map to pages forward
slash index.cshtml
and if it is domain.com forward slash
account
then by default it will first look
inside the pages folder for a page with
the name of account.cshtml
and if that does not find it then it
will look into the pages folder for an
account folder and in there it will see
if there is index index.cshtml
which is the default page
so routing in razer pages is pretty
straightforward as compared to mvc
routing where we have models views and
controllers
here in razer pages it is direct mapping
to how the files are stored in the
physical disk
so with that brief overview of routing
let's continue in the next video
in the last video
we saw how routing works in razer pages
in this video let me walk you through
all of the default pages that we have
inside our pages folder we have one
shared folder that has underscored
layout which is the default master page
of the application
here we have a header we have a body
where we will be rendering all of the
other pages so they will have a header
as well as a footer
we will also have all the css and
javascript that we want to include
throughout all the pages we can include
them in the master page directly
so what happens is inside render body we
will actually render any code that we
have inside the other pages
like we have index and privacy pages you
can see we are displaying some text of
welcome and inside the privacy we have
the header here that we are displaying
with privacy policy
so if we run the application again let's
examine what is the home page so inside
home page you see we have the header we
have the footer and whatever text we are
displaying right here inside the index
page is displayed between the header and
footer as we have defined
inside the underscore layout
so all of the code that we have here
will actually go inside the render body
right here
that's how master pages work so that is
our underscored layout page next we have
underscore validation scripts partial
when a name starts with underscore that
is usually a partial view or a partial
page partial pages are like user
components they cannot be accessed via a
url but they are being called inside
some other pages so it's like a table
that you want in 10 pages you just add
that table in a partial view and then
you call this partial view in all of
these 10 files and the table will
automatically be populated
in this partial view we just have two
scripts for validation
so in future in whichever page we want
validation we will be including this
partial view
also it is a good habit to name your
partial views with an underscore and
inside the shared folder
so it's easy to find them when we have
to
the next page that we have is underscore
view imports
here you can define the common name
space that you have in your website
so let's say in any of the pages if you
have to add the using statement many
times you can define them in this file
and that will be like a global
declaration
so once it is declared here it is
automatically available in all the other
files
one thing that you see here is we have
added tag helpers
so because of that we will be able to
use the built-in tag helpers that
the.net code team has provided
if we go to the shared folder underscore
layout and if we expand headers for
navigation we are using the asp page tag
helpers
you can see we are not using the href
tag here to navigate within razer pages
we have something called as asp page
the tag helpers for asp will start with
asp and then hyphen and then the name of
the tag helper
we can obviously create custom tag
helpers if we want
but the netcode team has provided all of
the default tag helpers to make
programming super simple
we will take a look at more tag helpers
as we proceed with the course but here
we have added that globally in our
application in view imports that's why
it will be available whenever we want to
use them
the next file is viewstart.cshtml
in this file we will define what is the
master page of our application
you saw that underscored layout is being
used as the master page but that is
because we have that defined here that
underscored layout should be the master
page
now what you can do is globally you can
have underscore layout as a master page
but on the individual razer page you can
still use the same razer syntax and
define a new master page
if you want you can define a different
master page but we will leave that with
underscored layout
the next view or page that we have is an
error page and this is the page that is
used to display the error messages when
you face them in production application
next what we have is the index page
right here where we are displaying the
text
now you might be wondering if you are
coming from web forms that with the
files there was a code behind file if
you are coming from an mvc background
you will be thinking where is the
controller
where does the c sharp code goes
with razer pages we have a dot cs file
if you expand that right here
now this is not a code behind file it is
just the naming convention
inside here you will notice we have the
index model and it inherits or
implements the page model
here we have an oncat handler and we
will have an on post handler that we can
add if needed
so here what we have to do is when this
page is being called on get if we want
to do something we will update that
inside the on cat handlers
in mvc we had action methods but inside
razor pages we call them as handlers
so we have on get handler and on post
handler
all of the code resides in these two
pages itself
cshtml has the page or ui code on what
we have to display and dot ces will have
the back end code
where if you want to retrieve some data
and pass that to the view or page we can
do that
when we are working with razer pages
that will be at the red page directive
at the top
and there will be a model that will be
added here
this model you can see it is index model
and if you go to the dot cs html that is
the exact class name
it is index model
based on that it automatically binds
both of this file and it knows that this
index.cshtml.cs
is the page model
for the index razer page
if this seems too much complicated do
not worry
when we start coding the application
everything will start making much more
sense
and similar to index we have a privacy
page and a privacy page model
so those are all of the default pages
that are available
inside the pages root folder
with that let me close all of these tabs
and let's take a look at program.cs file
in the next video
with that let me close all of the tabs
here and let's continue in the next
video
in this video let's take a look at tag
helpers
tag helpers are brand new to asp.net
core
microsoft looked at the success around
libraries like angular react and decided
that implementing an angular
directive-like experience in the new
asp.net was so important to the adoption
of dot-net core that they decided to
create tag helpers from grounds up
even though there are similarities
between angular directives and tag
helpers there is a major difference
tag helpers are for server-side
rendering while the angularjs directives
are all about client-side rendering
if you have worked with older versions
of net core we had something called as
html helpers
they are still around but tag helpers
are being modern with the tag like
approach so it's much user friendly
tag helpers are very focused around the
html element and are much more natural
to use as compared to html helpers
we will be working with tag helpers many
time in the application
but to just give you a brief overview
you can see in the first tab here we
have html helpers and tag helpers
simplifies all of them because we can
use the existing label tag and we will
just add a tag helper asp4 and we will
find that to a model
we have same tag helper right here as
well
then in the last example here i am
displaying tag helpers where previously
we were using html dot begin form
and now within the same form tag we have
the tag helpers of where it should be
posted
so you can see things are getting much
more simpler when we are using tag
helpers
that being said if you are coming to
dotnet brand new and you have never
worked with html helpers this is even
better
you do not have to worry about the old
syntax and what is different
we will be working with tag helpers in
the upcoming videos but i just wanted to
give you a brief snippet of what tag
helpers are and how they look like when
we are using the same tags we just use
the asp hyphen and then the tag helper
name
that being said we will explore all of
this in much more details in the
upcoming videos
when you will be working with a.net core
application you will see the return type
of action result
and it does not matter if you are using
an mvc application or a razer page
application
in both the cases you can see we have i
action result
in mvc we are returning back view in
this example and in razer page page
handler we are returning back to the
page
but the return type is i action result
i action result is a generic type that
implements all of the other return types
now if you want to be explicit about the
return type in both of these cases then
that would look something like this
if the return type is view you can write
view result
but in razer pages when we return back
to page you can write page result
so now what is the advantage of i action
result
so first let's understand some theory
so action result is a pattern class for
many of the derived classes that have
associated helpers
the i action result return type is
appropriate when multiple action results
written type are possible in an action
let's take a look at some of the helpers
and action result
so first let's take a look at what is
there in razer pages
a racer page can return content file not
found page a partial result and redirect
to different pages
for all of them we have return types
like content result file content result
not found result page result partial
result and so on
if we are working with an mvc
application we can return back views
partial views we can redirect to action
return json and so on
so if you are returning any one of these
then you can use the individual return
types for result based on the helper
method
but what if you were returning something
like this
right here in mvc you can see we are
returning if true let's imagine there
was some condition here based on that if
that condition is true you want to
redirect to action
else you want to return to view
this time you cannot have two different
return types
if you use view result here return view
is working but redirect to action will
throw error
similarly if you use redirect to action
result then redirect to action works but
return view
will give you error
if you are working on razer pages and
you have the same situation if you use
page wizard then return page will work
but redirect to page will fail
and if you use redirect to page result
then return page will fail
so what is the solution to all of this
the solution is to use i action result
in both the places
because this is a parent class so it
does not care which of its
implementation is being returned it will
be able to handle all of them
so that is a brief overview on how
action result will help us with the
return type from action method in mvc
application
or page handlers in a razor page
application
when we are working with any web project
we first need a database and that is the
heart of the application
in this case also we will have to add a
database and we will be doing that using
sql server
but for database i will be using entity
framework core code first
and in that we create a model and based
on that model we create a database table
so first we will have to create a model
in our project
so we will create a new folder call it
as model inside there we will create our
first class file which will be category
inside this class we will have to create
all the properties for all the columns
that we want in the table
let's say we want three columns we want
name of the category we want to display
order
and the last one will actually be the
most important one
all the tables require a primary key
so we will be adding an id column which
will be identity column in sql server
what i mean by that is when we create
any record we do not have to pass that
id
it will automatically
increment by one every time a new record
is created and that will be unique
so for all the three columns we will
have to create three properties
the first one should be the primary key
so for that we will type drop here which
is a snippet to create properties inside
visual studio
so we type prop and we press tab two
times
it creates an integer by default that's
fine we want to call that as id
the next property that we want is name
of the category which will be a string
and we will call that as name
the last one will be an integer
of display order
so with this we have created a class
which will be our table in the database
and it will have three properties or
three columns
now before we magically create the table
we need to do some more configuration
let's take a look at that in the next
video
we will be using entity framework core
to create the table and popular details
inside there
but when we create a table we need to
tell entity framework core that this
column will be an identity column and it
will be a primary key
let's say we also want to add a
validation that this name should be a
required and not null property inside
database
so how can we add all of those
validations and requirements
we have many attributes that are
available to define all of the
requirements
and all of them are defined inside data
annotations
so before the property here we can give
that an attribute inside a square
bracket
the attribute to make this column a
primary key is key itself
you will have to press ctrl dot here to
add the using statement and you will
press enter
now by default if a property name is id
entity framework core automatically
makes it a primary key
so this is optional
but if your name was something different
like let's say you wanted to make
display order a primary key then you
will have to explicitly say that
but if it is an id and if you have not
defined any primary key then it will
automatically set that as a primary key
that is good to know but i always like
to explicitly define so that when
someone opens up that model they can
directly say which one is the primary
key
next we want name to be required
and for that we have an attribute which
is required
that will make sure that name is a
required property when the sql statement
is created to actually create this
category table which we will see in the
upcoming videos
right now things are pretty simple we
created a class file it has few
properties and we added some easy
looking data annotations for our
requirement
how will we actually create this table
and database that is the main question
for that we will have to do some
configuration like adding a connection
string to our sql server adding some new
get packages so that we can use entity
framework core and sql server with our
project
don't be overwhelmed let's get started
by adding the connection string in the
next video
in this video we have to add connection
string so before we do that let me open
up sql server management studio
here the first thing that you require is
a server name
now many times a dot will work for
localhost but if that does not work you
can try localdb msequal localdb
whichever server name works for you
where you can connect that is the one
that you will use
i'm going to use just a dot because that
is working and that's how i have
configured sql server
i don't want the long one so i'll just
use the dot
once you are able to connect here to sql
server we will go back to our project
and we will add our connection string
now where exactly will we add that
connection string
all of the settings like secrets that
you have in the application you should
add that inside appsettings.json
if you examine we also have development
here so if you have more versions like
production staging preview for each one
of them we might have different settings
so you can add different settings inside
the individual file and based on the
environment name it will automatically
use the correct settings
for our local host we will use
appsettings.json
so inside appsettings.json if you
examine we have some key value
configuration
we have a block inside that we have
another block and finally we have key
value settings
when we are working with connection
string we can directly create a key
value pair right here
but connection string is something that
is common across all the application
that's why dot net core team has
provided a special block that you can
use for connection strings if you want
using that will make things a little
simple but if you want to go with a
custom block that will also work
you will just have to put some extra
effort to retrieve the connection string
we will use the default connection
string block that is provided with
dotnet core and that is connection
strings
once you press enter there you will
notice the curly brackets this means it
is a block
in there we can write our connection
string
you can give that any key name that you
want i'm going to call this default
connection
and after a colon in the double quotes
you will write your connection string
the first parameter here will be the
server name you will write equal to and
then whatever server you are able to
connect in sql server copy that and
write that here
i'm using a dot so that is what i will
use
then we will add a semicolon and we will
add the database name
you can call your database whatever you
want i'm going to use abby
finally we will have the security which
is trusted connection
is equal to true
that's all that we need for connection
string
the threshold connection is because i'm
using windows authentication to connect
to my sql server
so with that we have added connection
string in our project
but we need to configure our db context
so we can use this connection string
and configure entity framework core in
our application
it might seem daunting in the beginning
but do not worry once we set everything
up it will all make sense
let's continue in the next video
now we have our connection string we
have our category model how do we add
this model to database
in order to do that we will require
entity framework for in our project
so you will right click on your project
and you can select manage nuget packages
once you go there we will have to
install the package inside the browse we
will search for entity framework core
we have the first package here and i
have enabled the include pre-release
because right now dotnet 6 is in preview
so we will install that package in our
project
now while we are here i know we will be
using sql server and that requires its
own package as well so make sure you
search for sql and we have microsoft dot
entity framework core dot sql server
now when you install nuget packages if
you are using the preview version or
even if you are using the older version
always make sure that all the packages
in your project must be of the same
version
if you install one package in preview 7
and other in preview 6 it might not work
or if you install one package in dot net
5 and other in dot net 6 it still might
not work
so it has to be the same version or else
you might face issues later on
that being said i will install both the
nuget packages so that we can add the
configuration of entity framework core
in our project
perfect we will close the nuget package
manager and now we need to create a db
context so that we can interact with
entity framework core for database
so inside the project we will right
click
add a new folder
for data
inside there we will have to create our
class file for accessing the db context
you can call this anything you want i
like to call that application db context
now this file will implement the db
context or it will be like a data layer
that will connect our application with
the database so it must implement the db
context class inside the entity
framework core
so we will add a colon here and we will
write db context
now you will see the red squidly lines
because it does not find or does not
know what is this db context if you
press ctrl dot here you will see the
using statement inside microsoft dot
entity framework core
and db context is defined inside the
entity framework core to access and
manage the database
when we are creating a db context we
need to get the connection string as
options
then once you have configured this
inside this class we will be creating db
set for all the tables that we want in
our database
so the first table that we want is the
category model that we created
so in order to create that table you
will have to create a db set
so we will say public db set we will
write the model name which is category
you'll have to press ctrl dot to add the
using statement
and then here whatever name you give
will be the name of the actual database
i will call it the same category and we
will have getter and setter
so here if you named it category 1 your
table name will be category 1
so this is actually the name of the
table that you want inside your database
our application db context looks good
but we need to do one thing we have a db
context in our project and we have
connection string inside our app
settings.json
we need to configure this db context to
use our connection string that way it
will know how it can connect to the
database
let's see how we can do that in the next
video
now we need to add the connecting bridge
between our db context and connection
string
so we need to tell our application that
hey
you need to use this application db
context to interact as a db context and
you have to use the sql server with
connection string that is inside
appsettings.json
so all of that mapping will be done
inside program.cs
where we are adding services to the
container
the reason we are adding that as a
service here is once we add it here we
can extract that and use it with
dependency injection throughout the
application
so we will be adding db context as a
service in our application
now previously in dot net 5 all of this
was done inside startup.cs class file
but starting with dotnet6 they have
combined both startup and program.cs
into one single file
so here we are adding all the services
to the container and then we are
configuring the request pipeline
so now we no longer need multiple files
everything is much cleaner
so in order to add service to our
container we will say builder dot
services and the service that we want to
add is db context
so we want to configure the db context
which expects a class name
so here we have to tell that which class
in our application
is implementing db context
that is application db context
once you write that you will press ctrl
dot to add the using statements for
data
then here we have to pass the options
so we'll say options here goes to
and we will say options dot
we have use sql server inside the entity
framework core namespace
that way we are saying that for this db
context for database we want to use sql
server
and inside here we have to give the
connection string now how can we extract
our connection string from
appsettings.json
i said before that connection string is
a special block that is given by the.net
core team
so that's why they have given a special
method to access all the key values
inside that special block
you can do that by using builder dot
configuration dot they have given a
method get connection string
that will look for a key name inside app
settings.json
so inside connection strings what is the
key name we should look for
we should look for a key with the name
of default connection and we want its
value so we will copy default connection
and paste that in the key name when we
use get connection string
that will actually retrieve the
connection string and configure our db
context
now here you can see with application db
context we are passing the options
so inside our class where we have the
application db context we should
retrieve that options and pass that to
the base class of db context
so here we will have constructor using
the snippet ctor tab tab
and with this class we will receive db
context options
on application db context
we will call that as options and all we
want to do is pass that on to the base
class of db context
pretty simple and straightforward
but this line of code is very critical
if you do not do that your connection
will not work
now right now it might seem that we are
doing lots of magic things with setting
up application dp context some code in
program.cs and we are retrieving our
connection string from the app settings
but this is very basic connection that
you have to do with all.net core
applications when you want to use and
configure entity framework core
so this can be treated as basic steps
that you should remember and memorize
but what we are doing inside
we are just adding items to the
container so that we can extract and use
with the help of dependency injection
as we proceed with the course dependency
injection will make much more sense and
you will see how easy it is by adding
things to dependency injection to
extract when we want to use them
so with that basic configuration we are
almost there
next thing we have to do is we just need
to create our database we have all the
configuration that is ready
let's see how we can accomplish that
in the next video
now we need to add the connecting bridge
between our db context and connection
string
so we need to tell our application that
hey
you need to use this application db
context to interact as a db context and
you have to use the sql server with
connection string that is inside
appsettings.json
so all of that mapping will be done
inside program.cs
where we are adding services to the
container
the reason we are adding that as a
service here is once we add it here we
can extract that and use it with
dependency injection throughout the
application
so we will be adding db context as a
service in our application
now previously in dot net 5 all of this
was done inside startup.cs class file
but starting with dotnet6 they have
combined both startup and program.c into
one single file
so here we are adding all the services
to the container and then we are
requesting or configuring
and then we are configuring the request
pipeline
so now we no longer need multiple files
everything is much cleaner
so in order to add service to our
container we will say builder
dot services and the service that we
want to add is tb context
so we want to configure the db context
which expects a class name
so here we have to tell that which class
in our application is implementing db
context that is application db context
so you will press control
once you write that you will press ctrl
dot to add the using statements for
abbeyweb.data
then here we have to pass the options
so we'll say options here goes to
and we will say options dot
we have use sql server inside the entity
framework core namespace
that way we are saying that for this db
context for database we want to use sql
server
and inside here we have to give the
connection string
now how can we extract our connection
string from appsettings.json
i said before that connection string is
a special block that is given by the.net
core team
so that's why they have given a special
method to access all the key values
inside that special block
you can do that by using builder dot
configuration dot they have given a
method get connection string that will
retrieve all the
that will look for a key name inside
appsettings.json
so inside connection strings what is the
key name we should look for
we should look for a key with the name
of default connection and we want its
value so we will copy default connection
and paste that in the key name when we
use get connection string
that will actually
that will actually
that will actually retrieve the
connection string and configure our db
context
now here you can see with application db
context we are passing the options
so inside our class where we have the
application db context we should
retrieve that options and pass that to
the base class of db context
so here we will have constructor using
the snippet ctor tab tab
and with this class we will receive db
context options
on application db context
we will call that as options and all we
want to do is pass that on to the base
class of db context
pretty simple and straightforward
but this line of code is very critical
if you do not do that your connection
will not work
now right now it might seem that we are
doing lots of magic things with setting
up application dp context some code in
program dot
and we are retrieving our connection
string with the apps
from the app settings
but this is very basic connection that
you have to do with all.net code
applications when you want to use when
you want to use and configure entity
framework core
so this can be treated as basic steps
that you should remember and memorize
but what we are doing inside program.cs
we are just adding items to the
container so that we can extract and use
with the help of dependency injection
as we proceed with the course dependency
injection will make much more sense and
you will see how easy it is by adding
things to dependency injection to
extract when we want to use them
so with that basic configuration we are
almost there
next thing we have to do is we just need
to create our database we have all the
configuration that is ready
let's see how we can accomplish that
from the next video
in the next video
that all the configuration is done let's
finally create our database let me
switch back to sql server
and here if you examine the database we
do not have any abbey database
so we have connection string and
everything in place
in order to make connection with entity
framework and actually create sql we
will be adding migrations
what migrations will do is it will see
that inside application db context we
have a db set on category so it will
write a script to actually generate sql
that will create this table
it is pretty fancy and everything is
optimized
let me show you how we can run migration
first and then it will make sense
there are two commands that you should
remember
in order to run migration we will go to
tools nuget package manager and package
manager console
inside here we will have to write a
command to actually create migration
and that command is add migration
and we have to give our migration a
meaningful name
so we will call this add category to db
that is what we are doing
we added just category inside our
application db context
so let me press enter
and let me show you what error we get
we get the error the term add migration
is not recognized
now you remember we added nuget packages
of entity framework core and sql server
one more nuget package is needed for
this i want you to search this error and
find out what is the nuget package
okay i hope you were able to do that if
you just copy this
go to google paste that the first one
here if you scroll down there should be
the package name right here
so these are small things that you will
run into when you are developing and you
should always take google as your first
help station
because it is possible that someone else
has faced this error and that will help
you
so you will search for that nuget
package make sure the version is same
and you will install that
perfect that is done let me close that
we will go to package manager console
and run the same command one more time
this time it will create a new folder of
migration in your solution explorer and
load the migrations
great you can see a new migration have
been created and there is a new folder
with the name of migration
so let's analyze on what we are doing
inside the migration
you can see we have an up method and a
down method
down method is basically rolling back
the changes that we are doing if
something fails so let's ignore that
inside the up method we have migration
builder and we are saying that create a
table with the name of category
in that table we want columns the first
column will be id column of type integer
nullable is false and make sure that it
is a sql server identity column
you can see with the key attribute it is
configuring everything for us
then the next column name it is saying
that make sure that is not a nullable
column that is what we added as required
the last column is display order that is
also nullable false but the reason
behind that is it is of type integer
and then in the constrain you can see we
have a primary key on the id column with
the name of pk underscore category
so here you can see it is doing
everything that we wanted
you won't be able to see the raw sql
that is being executed but it is
optimized but in order to run this
migration and see the table in database
we need to add one more command
so tools new get package manager console
and the command is update database
let's press enter
what it does first is it will check at
that connection string does that
database exist
if it does then it will just push the
migration that we added
if it does not then it will create that
database and then it will run the
migration
so now the database should be created
and in there we will have two tables
we have our category table which will
have the three columns that we created
perfect and we have a table which keeps
track of all the migrations that have
been applied
so let's examine the ef migrations
history and you can see it has the
migration id which is name of the
migration that you can see here and the
product version
that way entity framework code knows
that this migration has already been
applied so next time when you run the
command update database it will not
reapply this migration
pretty smart to track everything that is
being done with entity framework
so great with that our database has been
created
successfully let me close everything
here and let's continue from the next
video
now we have our category table that has
been created inside the database
so what we want to do is we want to
create a new page where we can display
all the categories
when we are working with razer pages it
will be inside the pages folder as
compared to views in mvc
so inside pages we have the home page
which is index.cshtml
we want to create pages for listing all
the categories creating category editing
category and deleting category
rather than cluttering everything in one
place we will create a new folder inside
pages
i will name the folder as categories and
in there we will create a new razer page
the first page that we want to create
will be used to display a list of all
the categories so we can name that as
index
we will select the razer page empty here
because we want to start with a clean
and empty page rather than working with
a template
so select empty and we will hit add
button
name of the razer page we will keep that
as index.cshtml
let's add that as soon as you add that
you will notice two files were added
one is the cs file and we have the ces
html
the dot cs file will be the file where
we have page model for our index page
you can see the model that is being
referenced here is inside appy web pages
categories index model and this
particular namespace will be the
namespace that you see on top here
so that is how it is binding everything
together and we have our class index
model
now we used entity framework code to add
migrations to create our category table
which was inside model and our db
context was application db context
inside program.cs we registered that
service in our container
since we have registered the service
whenever we have to access database we
do not have to create a new object of
application db context
what happens here is the service is
already available in the container
so we just need to tell our container
that hey i need to use the db context to
access database so give me an
implementation of this class
how do you do that
that will be done using constructor
inside the cs file we need to create a
read-only application db context and
we'll add the using statement i will
call that underscore tb
now we want an implementation of this
class
using dependency injection
that will be done inside constructor
so we'll type ctor press tab twice this
is a snippet to create constructor
quickly in visual studio
now if you have registered anything
inside the container and you want its
implementation you simply tell here the
implementation that you want
so we will write that we want an
implementation of application db context
and give that to us in a variable with
the name of db
we will assign our private variable
which is underscore db the value of db
so now our underscore db will have an
implementation that already connects to
the database and we can use that
inside the onget method we need to
retrieve list of all the categories
in order to retrieve that we need to
create a property that will hold all the
category list
so on top here we can create an indium
variable on category and let's call that
categories
next thing that we have to do is we need
to populate this categories list so this
we need to populate from the database so
we'll say underscore db and with entity
framework core when you write dot here
it will display all of the tables or db
sets that we added
so if you scroll down here you should
see the category db set that we added
so we want to retrieve underscore db dot
categories
this will retrieve all the list of
categories
we did not have to write any fancy sql
like select star from categories table
we did not have to open a connection we
did not have to close connection no
cleanup was needed
entity framework code takes care of
everything and we just access db context
and then on category we have multiple
methods to create update delete and much
more
but if you just say underscore
tb.category
it will automatically retrieve all of
the categories and store that in this
variable
our get method looks good inside the
index page model for categories
now what i want to do is inside shared
we have underscored layout
we can navigate to two pages we have
index and privacy
rather than privacy i want to navigate
inside the categories folder we have the
index page
since we want to go in folder we will
not use the forward slash we can
directly say categories
and then forward slash what is the page
name
that is index
so here we have to use the exact route
that we have in folder structure
if you are using mvc you have
controllers and action method
but with razer pages everything is
simple
actual way in which the folders are
organized will be the exact route so
routing is pretty simple in razer pages
we will change the link here to display
categories
and let me save this run the application
right now it is running things using the
abi web profile but we will change that
to iis express in just a second
but if we go back we have the categories
tab here and you can see the url in the
bottom left it displays the categories
let's hit this button and see what
happens
we see an index page here but no data is
displayed
we don't want to work with data right
now let's go to our code behind here and
let me add a debugging point
let's go back and let me just refresh
the page
we hit our breakpoint if i press f10 it
will take us to the next line
and then if we examine what got
populated in our categories it will be
empty because we do not have any records
so it yielded no result let me add a
breakpoint on this line remove the one
before
and let me switch to sql server we can
keep our application running actually i
can hit the continue button to go back
inside sql server
let me expand the database tables let's
directly edit the top 200 rows
let me create a name test and display
order too
so we have one record in our database
now
if we go back to the application and hit
categories one more time it hits our
breakpoint again this time we should see
one record that is being retrieved
and perfect we see all the details
populated
so with that you can see we are
successfully able to retrieve all of the
records for categories from database
in the next video
let's work on displaying these
categories inside the index page right
here
now that we have seen how to retrieve
the categories inside the get handler we
need to actually display that in the
razer page
so if we go back to index.cshtml
this is the index of categories and not
of the main page
so inside the index of categories we
want to display all of the categories
if you have only worked with web forms
and never worked with razer pages inside
razer pages you can have html code as
well as c sharp code
so you can have if else you can create
variables assign them values as well as
html directly at one place
so let me add a div here give it a class
of container
and i will give it padding three these
are just bootstrap classes to creating a
container and inside there we will
create a row so we will give it
bootstrap class of row padding top of 4.
this will be one row on the complete
screen now that one row we want to
divide in two pieces first on the left
hand side i want to display a title
since bootstrap divides the row in 12
parts if we want to divide those 12
parts into two pieces for the left hand
side we will have six piece and right
hand side we will have six piece
so we will have div here give it a class
of column six
to combine the first six pieces in one
single element
here we will display an h2 heading
and we will give it a bootstrap class of
text primary
we want to display here the heading
which is category list
that looks good
here we will have later part which is
div of class column six
and we will add buttons inside this div
later on
this looks good
let me add some space so to be our tags
and then we want to add a table to
display our categories so we will use a
table tag
inside this table we will have a t head
for header inside t head we will have t
r and t h tags this is just html tags
that we are working with
inside the first heading we want to
display the category name
and inside the next edge we want to
display
the display order
now that is good for the heading we want
to have a body where we will be
displaying the actual values
now if we have 10 entries inside
category inside t body we will have a tr
tag and td just like we have th inside
the heading
here we want to display the actual value
of category name
and then we will have another td which
will have value of display order
now if we have 10 categories inside
database
we want this tr to repeat 10 times
because we want to display all the
category name and display order
so if you were working with c sharp you
would be using for each loop
we will do the same right here
in order to use a c sharp code we need
to add sign
and then we can just write for each
statement
with for each we need an object to
iterate so we will say variable obj in
and what we want to iterate on will be
inside our index model
this index model represents what we have
in the ces file
in order to show you if you right click
here and if you click go to definition
it takes us here and you can see in here
we have the variable for categories
so we can access this categories since
it is an i innumerable we will iterate
through that
because inside the get we are already
populating that categories so we should
be good
so back to the ui we want to iterate
over that i innumerable of category
to access this model that we have right
here inside the lowercase m
we will have to use a keyword which is
model but this time the m will be
capital
so whatever we have inside the smaller
case model here anywhere inside the view
or page if you want to access that you
will use the capital m model
so if you press model dot you can see
all the models that are available inside
the ces file
so we want to iterate over the model dot
categories and we will have a curly
bracket here so each categories inside
the model dot categories will have a
temporary name of obj
this is how for each works
so for each one of the object we want to
display a tr tag and we want to display
the values
to display value we need to access the
obj variable right here
so again we will use the add sign obj
dot and we will see all the properties
that are available we want to select
name from there
the next one that we have is display
order so we can say obj dot display
order
we will add some width on both the td
tags
with that in place let me save this and
run the application
if we go to our categories
we have the category list heading and we
have a table here but i want to give it
some bootstrap classes
so we can go back and on the table tag
right here we can add class is equal to
i will add three bootstrap classes of
table table bordered and table striped
also i will give it a style of width
hundred percent
now when we are making changes inside
css or even anything inside the ui side
of cshdml once we save it we can go back
and actually refresh and it should make
those changes visible
but right now it is not working
we already added the razer runtime
compilation for this particular package
but the reason that is not working is
right now there is a bug and you have to
manually add a statement
so for that we will have to go to
program.cs
where it is adding the razer pages you
also have to add a command here add
razor runtime compilation
this should have been done automatically
because we selected the razer pages but
i believe since dotnet 6 is in preview
they will fix this down the road
but if this is not present
add that and let's run the project one
more time
if you go to categories now you will see
a nice table
with this you can see how we are able to
display all of the categories inside our
razor page that we created
if you examine the url here it is only
categories and not index because index
is there by default if you write index
manually and press enter it will load
the same page
perfect with that let's continue in the
next video but before that let me change
the setting here to use iis express that
way we don't have the command prompt
every time
now our index page is working as
expected for categories and inside the
cs file we have the get handler before i
proceed on the next task to create a
category let me switch back to database
here and we will write a query
so select top thousand and let me just
delete the record
so we'll delete the category that was
present and now there is no categories
and once we make that change if we go
back and run the application
perfect everything is clean
now i want to add a button here to
create a category
we have not added that page right now
but we will do that
let's go back to our index here and we
left a space inside the right hand side
of the category list so we want an
anchor tag
now we want to go to a new page that we
will create inside the categories folder
with the name of create
so for that there are tag helpers the
tag helpers that we want to use here is
asb page
if you were working with mvc then you
will use action and controllers
but with razer pages everything will be
asb page
we want to navigate to a new page with
the name of create since this is inside
the same folder of categories we do not
have to explicitly mention here the
categories before create page
it will understand that by default
so we want to go to a new page of create
and we want to give it class of btn ptn
primary
inside the anchor tag
we want to display create new category
now the application is running and we
enable the razer runtime so if you do f5
it should display the button
if you click here nothing happens
this does not mean that your link is
broken
nothing is happening here because that
page does not exist
if this was an mvc application it will
take you to a page not found but with
razer pages it is different
if the link is broken
it does not display and not found it
will just stay there
so in the next video let's create the
new razer page to create a new category
just like we added the index page to
list all the categories we need to add a
new razer page inside the categories
folder to create category
so we will add new razer page empty
looks good this time you have to call
this as create
you can see here we are creating a razor
page and not a razer view
razer views are used in mvc application
and they do not have a page model
we will create a razor page and let's
hit the add button
this time the model you can see it is
create model and if you examine the dot
ces you will see the class is create
model
so that is how it links both of the file
now right now we have the on get handler
inside the on get handler of index we
were retrieving all of the categories to
display inside the page
when we are creating a category we do
not have to populate any information
inside the create page we will just have
an empty text box for user to enter the
display order and name of the category
so that will be empty since we do not
have to do anything inside the onget
let's work on the view itself
inside view we will have a form in which
user will enter name and display order
and they will hit the submit button so
we will have a form tag here this will
be of method
post
then we will add some bootstrap classes
we will add a div give it a class of
border padding 3 margin top of four
inside there i will add another div give
it a class of row
and padding bottom of two
and i will just add a heading h2 that
will display create category
and an hr for a horizontal line
after this div i will add another div
give it a class of margin bottom three
and in here we want to display the label
which is name and then we want an input
field of type text
i will copy this and paste it one more
time next property that i want is
display order
and type will be text
of course in html you remember we give
that some name like display order
the first one here we can give it a name
of category name
after that we will have a button of type
submit
and we can give it some bootstrap
classes of btn btn primary
and a constant width of 150 pixels
let's call this button as create
so perfect now we have a form to create
our category let's run the project and
take a look at that
so we go on categories and now if we
select create new category we see our
new form
let's continue with the form in the next
video
now in a typical web form what happens
is we have a name for this input field
and display order so when we post that
inside there we will try to extract that
based on the name and we will see what
value was appended
but with razer pages we have something
special
we can bind this input text directly to
a category model and then we can use
that model or rather have those values
available inside the post handler
so we will be binding this to a model
in order to bind a ui to a model we have
to create that property or model inside
the model of the ui which is create
model that is inside the cshtml.cs
so just like inside index we created an
i enumerable of category and then we
binded that right here to extract using
model.categories
we can do something similar inside
create.cshtml we do not want an eye
indium variable we just want one single
category
so we will create a category property
and we can access this property inside
our ui right here
inside the index.cshtml
we saw the tag helper asp page
that is used to redirect
similarly we have a tag helper that
binds a property
and that is asp4 here we have to write
the name inside our model
to extract that we will need the add
sign we will say model dot and that is
inside category
inside category this is for name
and with that we also do not have to
define any type or name
everything will be done automatically
and all the bindings will be done
we will just add some bootstrap classes
for styling
now this will create an input field
similarly we have something for label
so if we have a label here and if we use
asp4
we can use accurate model here but if
you do not want to use the attribute
model when you are using asp4
it is smart enough to automatically bind
the models
so you can directly say category if you
want and dot name
that is pretty simple but if you don't
see that option you can always use at
the model to access everything inside
the model that is defined right here
so we are just adding a label here with
the tag helper of category name
let me copy these two lines and paste
them for display order as well
we will just have to change the property
name to display order
with that let me save the changes go
back and refresh
and we see this error because we also
modified the dot ces file we will
actually have to rerun the project
if it was just the cshtml or the ui then
we do not have to rerun our project
so let's go to categories here and if we
hit create new categories we have name
and display order
let me press f12 here and inspect the
element
you can see on this element it
automatically populates the id and name
and you can see name is category.name
so it does all of the binding along with
the type equals to text automatically
so you can see how life gets easy with
tag helpers
now once we enter any of the details
here and we hit the submit button
we want to fetch those details inside
the post handler
we only have a get handler right now
so let's add a post handler and continue
from the next video
now we need to create an onpost handler
by default only get handles are created
if you were working in an mvc
environment then you would create an
on-post action method
but in razer pages we create handlers
so creating handlers is simple we will
call public and then the return type
i want to make this an async method so i
will add async and task of i action
result i action wizard i'm using because
i want to return to some page or
redirect to a view
so that will be the return type and we
will call this on post
when we have to name handlers it will
always start with the keyword on and
then we have the http verb that this
handler will do
this handler will support the post
action method so that's why we will call
onposthandler
now if you have multiple post handlers
that you want in a razor page you can
give this a handler name after the post
like you can say on post create and then
you can have on post edit
that can be two post handlers
but right now we just want to create one
post handler to fetch the details that
user entered and create that category
inside the database
so here on post we will receive a
category object let me call that as
category
and let's create that inside our
database
in order to work with database we need
dependency injection with the
application db context
so first let me create an application db
context we will do control dot for the
using statement and i will require a
constructor so ctor
and i will retrieve that from dependency
injection and assign that to my local
variable
then we want to create the category that
we received right here
so for that we will be using underscore
db
and we have to define our model which is
category on there we have more methods
we have methods to add remove update and
much more
the first thing that we want to do is
add
now you can use this ad but we have
added the async method so let's use the
async implementation add async
in there it expects a category entity
that we have fetched with our on post so
we will add that
now when you are using async method we
will have to update that before we
proceed further
when you write this one line it is
telling entity framework that hey this
is the category object that you have to
add inside the category table
but it does not tell entity framework to
go and do that right now
in order to tell that there is a
different statement we will say await
underscore db
dot we have save changes async
when you write the save changes async at
that time it gets all of the items that
it has to change inside database and
makes all of those changes so if you
forget to write save changes it knows
that it has to do that but it will not
save them to the database and when it
redirects or something that will be lost
so always make sure to save the changes
once the changes are saved we want to
return back to the index page
you see it displays redirect to action
but that is not valid in our application
because we are using razer pages
so with razer pages we have redirect to
page and we want to redirect to the
index page
with that let me save this add a
debugging point and let me restart the
application since we've made changes to
the code behind
let's go to our categories here
we have create category let me enter
test and a display order hit the create
button
now as soon as you do that if you
examine the category you can see they
are populated
let's hit continue here
and great that is created
so with this we are able to create
categories inside our application
but i want to show you one more thing
let me close the application and here we
are fetching the category object and we
are adding that
we already have a model here for
category so it is something that is
redundant
to avoid that dotnet core team has
provided a special attribute which is
bind property
when you use bind property you no longer
have to write it here it automatically
does the binding
with the ui that we have on the screen
and that will be populated inside the
same object
so then we can use this category and add
that like this
this will make things much simpler
let's run the application and try to
create one more category
so let's create test one this time
and great it is working as expected
now this is not needed right now but i'd
like to show you something else
let's say you had three properties that
you were binding here and inside the
post
in that case you will have to write
blind property on each one of them
from dotnet code 2.1 they have added a
special property that you can apply
directly at the glass level
that is bind properties
what that will do is all the properties
that you have here and you are using
inside the ui it will bind all of them
automatically so that you do not have to
individually add bind property
so with that if we run the application
our create should still work the same
way
even though we just have one category
it's good to know that we have that
option available if needed
let's try to create a new category test
2 here
and great it's working
so with this our create functionality is
working as expected
let's add some styling here and continue
from the next video
i want to change the themes that we are
using in our application
so if we go to google and if we search
for
bootswatch.com this provides free themes
for bootstrap
if you scroll down there are all the
themes that are available
i will go with the cyborg theme for this
course
you can download the minified version or
the bootstrap.css
let me download the bootstrap.css i will
copy everything that we have open here
let me minimize this
and we'll stop the application
let me add a new css right here
this will be stylesheet
i will call this bootswatch cyborg let's
add that
and i will paste it here
let me close this and if you open
site.css
they have added some different color for
pt and primary i will remove those two
that looks good now if we go to
underscore layout we can modify the
bootstrap reference that we have here to
the new css
so inside the css folder we have
bootswatch cyborg
let me scroll down where we are using
the bootstrap js bundle let's go back
here to bootstrap.com
and let's scroll down we have the cdn
for js with popper
let me copy this and we will paste that
right here
this will make sure that we are using
the latest one for our course
lastly if i go back with bootstrap we
also have icons that are available to
use
you can see there are quite a few icons
that we can use in our application
to get started let's go to the install
tab
and we have the cdn that we can copy
let me paste that with the style sheets
so perfect with that we'll be able to
use icons that are available with
bootstrap
now that the css is updated let's run
the project and see what happens with
the new theme
things will be little different
perfect that looks good but i want to
change the navigation here to be dark as
well
so if you go back
and if you examine the theme details you
will notice we have a dark navigation
let's use that
in order to do that we will go back to
underscore layout rather than navbar
light this will be navbar dark and the
bg will also be dark
let's go back and refresh
and this looks much better
so you can see how easy it was to switch
themes
now i do not like the header and
background both the same color so if we
go back to boots watch let me find out
some other theme
we can use this darkly theme and you can
see the navigation is a little grey
let me switch that i will download the
bootstrap.css
cut everything here
let's go back to the application
we can remove that and paste the new
code if we go back and refresh here
great this looks much better let me
remove the two borders here
and in underscore layout we will search
for border
we will remove the border bottom we have
one more
right here
and perfect
let's go back and refresh
great the ui looks good
inside the footer i will say bg dark to
get the little gray shade
great this looks much better
the only thing that is missing is our
headings here are in black so we'll have
to go back there
and remove the text star to give them
the white color
let me save this and refresh
and great
now the create category looks much
better
let me also align this on the right hand
side so we will go to our index
and where we have the button here we can
give it the class of text and with
bootstrap five
great
now while we are here let's also use the
icons of bootstrap
so inside the icons if we go to the top
let me search for pencil
we have this pencil square we can copy
this
go back to the create new category
before that let me add the icon
and a space
with that you can see adding icons is
super easy
so with that the design looks good
now what i want to do is inside create
category if you try to hit create button
you will run into an exception
it says this equal exception cannot
insert null values in name that is
because the column doesn't allow nodes
our entity framework core was smart
enough in migrations to add the not null
based on the required property
but here we need validations so that we
do not see this ugly exception
let's do that in the next video
now we want to add validations on the
create window
if we go back to our project and if we
examine our model category you can see
for name we added a required validation
so we want to make sure that this basic
validations that we have defined here
should be applied when a user is
inputting those values
checking for those validations is super
easy with dotnet core
first let's take a look at server side
validation
so that will be done inside the dot ces
file when a user is actually creating
the category
we are using a model here to insert
inside the database so we have something
known as model state
that model state will get the bindings
and its state and in that we have an is
valid flag this will check if the model
state dictionary is valid or not
model state dictionary will have a key
value pair for each entity that is there
in our model
so inside category it will have whether
the name is valid or the display name is
valid or not because we are entering
both of them inside the create ui
so let's examine model state dot is
valid
if that is valid only then we want to
create if that is not valid we want to
return back to the page
and that is how it should be
but let's add a debugging point here and
let's examine what actually happens
let me restart the application because
we made a change inside the page model
so with that let's go to categories and
try to create an empty category
we do not hit our breakpoint that is
because the breakpoint will only be hit
if the model state is valid
let me add a debugging point right there
and hit the create button
if you hover on model state you can
examine all of the properties in there
the is valid is set to false which means
the model state is not valid
now why is it not valid
that you can examine by going to the
result view you can see there are two
properties that it is monitoring and
both of them are not valid
the name is not valid because it is a
required field and the display order is
also not valid because it is an integer
field if you enter null in there that is
not valid as well
let me hit continue here and this time
you don't see the ugly screen because if
the model state is not valid we are
returning back to the page
this time let me enter name
and then hit create
the model state will still be not valid
because of our display order
this time the error count is 1 and if
you expand the result view you can see
name property is now valid but the
display order is invalid
so with that we can easily check our
model state and only if the model state
is valid then we create else we return
back to the view
but that is not helpful
we should display an error message
saying what actually is invalid so that
user can fix that
doing that is super simple with dotnet
core
if you go to
create.cshtml we have a special tag
helper to display the validation errors
so right after the property or wherever
you want to display we will have to add
a span tag
and there is a tag helper asp validation
form
here we have to write the name of model
property that we want to bind with this
validation
we want to check for validation category
dot
so if there are any errors with
category.name
that will be displayed in the span right
here
and we will also add a class of text
danger for the red color
let me copy this and paste it for
display order so we can monitor both of
them
once you save that let me go back and
refresh the page
let me try to hit the create button
it hits our breakpoint
and we get an error let me just stop the
application
i get that from time to time even though
i did not edit anything while the
project was running
so let me restart the application
and this time we should see the error
messages
so let's hit the create button and great
you can see it displays a default
message the name field is required and
the value empty is invalid
so with that you can see how easy it was
to display validations from server side
now the way you can tell this is server
side is if you examine the tab here
every time we hit the button it reloads
so it goes to the server and then it
finds out that something is invalid it
returns back and it displays the error
message
with that let's continue in the next
video
these are the default validations that
we have at the model level
but what if we want a custom validation
let's say we want a validation that the
name and display order cannot be same
how can we implement that custom
validation and display that message
right here
so let me close the application and we
will have to implement that validation
at the server side
we can say if category dot name
is equal equal to category dot display
order we will have to convert that to a
string
if these are the same then we want to
add an error message
so to manually add an error we can
access the model state and in there we
have a method add model error
now this method requires two parameters
first is a key name and next is the
error message
so you can name this key anything that
you want you can even keep that string
dot empty because we don't want to put
anything in the key
but if you are adding more than one
model errors then you cannot have string
dot empty for both of them because this
is a key value
so you can use distinct key name and
then the error message let me say the
display order cannot exactly match the
name
so now we have added a custom error
right here in our model state as soon as
you add this the model state even if it
was valid before this execution will now
no longer be valid and i will show that
but where will this error be displayed
because if you go to create.cshtml
we have the validation for individual
properties that are displayed right here
but we have something where we can
display the summary of all the
validation
so let's say right here we want to do
that then that will be inserted div and
we have a tag helper asp validation
summary we can keep that as all
in that case it will display all the
validation summary at the top as well as
at the individual level
let me save this and run the application
if you go to categories here
and try to create an empty category
let me remove the debugger and continue
and great you can see here we see the
validation summary and same properties
are displayed right here
now this time let me enter test and a
display order
i will actually add the debugging point
again on post and let me hit the button
if you examine the model state right now
you will notice that it is valid
we will add a debugging point and let's
continue
it seems like it went through and of
course it did because the name and
display order were not the same
let's keep them same again continue
continue again it is adding the model
state error
let me add another debugging point hit
continue
and if you examine this time it is not
valid because we added a custom model
error based on our requirement
so if we remove all debugging point and
hit continue
we see the custom error that display
order cannot exactly match the name
so this is how you can add custom
validations
now i want to show you one more thing
you can see we have used the tag helper
to display label
if we go back we have the label for
display order and name
it is using the exact same name as
property
but what if we want to display something
else what if we want to display a space
between display order because inside the
error messages also it displays the same
format
to do that we have lots of data
annotations that are available to help
things
let me go back to category and stop the
application
here we have the required data
annotation similarly we have a data
annotation which is display
and there we can provide a name of
whatever we want it to display
so let's call that display space order
once you do that if you save and run the
application now wherever it has to
display the name of the property it will
use this display attribute and whatever
name we have given
so if you go to categories create new
category
you see the space between display order
and if you write same thing you have
that in the custom validations
and my bad this will not change because
we are adding the custom string so if
you want that you can always change that
here
i thought for a second it was retrieved
from the property name but that's not
the case
but you can see we can change the
display attribute to display label
wherever it is being displayed
next we also have custom data
annotations other than required display
and key
if you go back to the microsoft
documentation you can see all of the
annotations that are available and
there's quite a few of them
we have one here that is range that
checks if the specified number is
between a range of values
if you scroll up we have the min length
phone number key attribute that is the
one that we used and we should have a
display as well
let's see how we can use the range
attribute when we have the display order
let's say we want to make sure that
display order should always be between 1
and 100
so here we can use the range attribute
and it expects two parameters
one is the minimum value and maximum
will be hundred
along with that if you want to specify
what error message should be displayed
if that condition is not true you can
customize that if you do not like the
default message
so we will display our custom error
message and let's see this in action
if we try to hit the create button we
have the invalid but if we enter let's
say 222 hit create now we see our custom
error message
so there are lots of data annotations
that are available that you can check
out on the documentation
but we saw the use of display as well as
ranged data annotation
with that let's continue from the next
video
the validations that we have seen so far
are server side validation
on each request it goes back to the
server and then displays the validation
what if you want to use client-side
validation
the custom validations like name and
display order should not be same will be
server-side
in order to validate things on
client-side with the.net core
application inside the shared folder we
have a script which is validation
scripts partial
here we have the jquery to do some
validations on the client side
but this is not included by default in
all the pages
so in pages where you want to do
client-side validation all you have to
do is include this partial view
partial views are meant for that purpose
itself they are created to be used
inside some other view
so let's go to our create and how do we
add a partial view
partial views are like user components
if you come from the traditional.net
application
since inside there we only have script
tags so if you have to add any script
tag inside your view you have to create
a new section
so we will create a section for scripts
and inside that we will use the razer
code we want to add a partial view
so for that we have a partial tag helper
and we have name there where we need to
write the exact name
make sure you do not make any spelling
mistake there
or else it won't work
so with that our partial view is added
if this partial view did not have just
script it had some code then you could
have added that within your html like
this
but since it is scripts we will add that
inside the section of scripts
if you have any javascript code that you
want that will also be added within this
section itself
so on razer page you can add a section
to handle all of the javascript
once you do that you do not need any
other changes
we just need to run the application and
see inside validation in action
let's go to categories here
and let's hit the create button this
time the page will not reload
you can see all the validations are done
on the client side
if you go to the page model and add a
debugging point when you hit create it
does not hit the debugging point anymore
but the custom validation that we have
here is still done on server side so if
we add one and one hit create button it
goes to the on post and then it displays
the validation
so if you want to be fancy you can do
that validation in javascript as well
but by default the dot net core does not
display the custom validations on client
side and that also makes sense
now before i end this video what if we
want to display this validation inside
the name
so basically when we are doing this you
can see we have validation that name
field is required i want to display that
validation for the name property
doing that is super simple we stop the
application and the key here
we will have to change that to be
category
dot name
let's run this and see what
happens let's hit continue
and great you can see now we are binding
that directly
so if you want to bind some custom model
state errors to a property you just need
to provide that key name and it will
automatically
do the binding
so with that let me remove the debugging
point and let's continue from the next
video
the dot create category is working as
expected let's work on editing a
category
so for that we will have to go back to
the categories page
and when we click here the navigation
doesn't seem to work
let me go to underscore layout
where we have the navigation here we
will have to add a forward slash
let me save that refresh
and perfect that's much better
we will always need a forward slash and
then the complete path because we have
the pages as the root directory so after
that how do you navigate to index so
after pages change the directory to
categories in there we have index
now in the index page we want to add two
buttons of edit and delete
let me go back while the application is
running inside index we have two th tags
i will add another th here
and inside the table row we will add a
td
inside this td we want to add two links
the first one should take you to an asp
page using tag helpers it should take us
to edit page
and we will give some bootstrap classes
ptn btn primary
and margin x of 2.
inside the anchor tag we want to display
an icon to edit
so we can go back
set the bootstrap icons we used pencil
we can copy that and paste it for edit
next we want a link for delete so let me
copy this
paste it one more time for delete
that will be btn danger
let's go back
we will search for a trash icon
let's copy that
and paste it here
if we scroll up we are using pencil for
create new so let me change that to
something else
like a plus sign
so we have the plus square let's use
that
let me save this go back to our
application and refresh
perfect so we have all the icons let me
go back and add some styling so right
inside the td
let me add a div give it a class of
width 75 percent vtn group and row
and we will close that
let's refresh
and this looks much better
so if we go back we will have to add two
pages one for edit and one for delete
now when we are editing any of the
category here we need to know that which
category user selected
so we need to pass the id when the user
clicks on any of these buttons
we have a special tag helper for that
when a user clicks this link we want to
pass something to the route so we have
asp route and then after hyphen we can
give it any name let's call that as id
and then the value that we have to pass
is inside this obj so we'll use the
razer at obj dot id
that will pass a variable with the name
of id
to the get handler of this particular
page
so let's create that page and work on
that in the next video
now that we are passing the asp route id
with the actual category id to this edit
page let's create that page
if you want you can create a new page
inside categories
what if we want to copy this create and
reuse that
the reason to reuse is because the view
or the ui will be exactly the same it's
just rather than displaying an empty
page we will have to display all of the
items that are loaded
so let me copy this create and paste it
one more time
then to edit we will have to stop the
application let's press f2 and change
the name to edit
if we expand this we have edit.cs html
you think that is sufficient right
but once you make this change let's try
to run our application
we will have some error messages
what is the reason behind that
i want you guys to pause the video and
try to see if you can find out what is
the reason we just copied the create and
we modified the name to edit but it is
failing
i hope you guys were able to figure out
the actual reason
let's take a look at edit.cs html and
create.cshtml
if i toggle between them you can see
that the create model is being used for
both of the pages that cannot happen
each page will have its own unique model
so what actually happened is when we
copied and pasted inside the cshtml it
is using the same model for both create
and edit
we have to change the name of this model
you can name it anything that you want
i'll call this program model we will
have that constructor and inside edit we
will have to use the same
with that if you run the application
everything will work as expected
so that was the main culprit over there
but we should name this as meaningful as
possible so let's call this as edit
model and we will change that in all the
places
when you were copying and pasting things
inside mvc this was not an issue because
it would rename the class and everything
would work when you are working with
controller
with view they don't have a tight bind
because there is no dot cs in mvc
but when you work with razer pages if
you are copying and pasting make sure to
change the model in both the page model
as well as the ui page
so with that we have added the edit
razer page
now one thing that will be different
inside edit razer page is inside the
oncat we will actually have to retrieve
the category
and we will have to pass that to the
view or the ui that we have here
inside the view it is already binding
that to category.name and display order
so we just need to populate the category
object right here
in order to find that we will be
receiving id in the parameters here
so let's write that
as i said before insert the
index.cshtml i am passing the route with
the name of id
so inside edit.cshtml.cs
we can fetch that directly here and
based on that id we will retrieve the
category from database
so underscore tb dot category dot
now we want to find a category based on
id
that could be done in many ways
the first one here is find
in find if you write id it will
automatically find that and assign the
category
find will work on primary key of the
table
so the id that you pass here must be the
primary key of category table
and that is the case because of that it
will automatically find that record and
assign that to our category
now similar to find i have few more
methods that i want to show you
the next method that we have is first
our default
we have both first as well as first our
default
what will happen with first is we need a
lambda expression here and we will say u
dot id is equal equal to the id that is
passed here
here we are saying that from category
table find me the first record that
matches the id which is equal to the id
that we are passing here
straightforward now the difference
between first and first or default is
that if it does not find any record with
that id first we'll throw an exception
first or default will just return null
that is the difference between first and
first or default
another way of finding that is using
single and single or default
you can use single when you expect only
one entity to be returned because in
single if more than one entities are
returned that will throw an exception as
well
whereas in first if more than one
entities are returned it will just
ignore everything else and send you the
first one
so single is more strict when it comes
to returning values
inside single or default if nothing is
found it will return null inside single
that will throw exception
so similar to first and default
and then here again you will need lambda
expression so u dot id is equal equal to
the id
last but not the least is not the
favorite approach when we are working
with one entity here you will have a
where condition and you will say value
goes to u dot id
is equal equal to id
so it will retrieve all of the records
where the id matches
with this statement it can return 10
records it can return 20 records
wherever the id matches
so on that once you retrieve that you
will have to call first or default
these are just multiple ways of doing
the same thing
i prefer either find or first or default
i'll just comment this out so that you
can play around with them
but that will retrieve the category and
assign that to our category object
and inside the post action method what
we are doing is we are adding the
category we do not add the category this
time we just want to update
so on db set of category we have an
update method and since that is not
async we will have to remove the update
keyword
with that it will automatically update
the properties that are different based
on the primary key
so you can see how easy it is to update
any of the category
let's run our application and give this
a try
now before i run this we'll just go back
to the edit view i'll have to change
this create to edit and where we have
create button we will just have to
change the text to update
because it is anyways submitting back so
the form on post handler will be
triggered automatically
let's go back to our application
and let's try to update a category
let's hit update
now you might think here that update is
working but actually it's not
let's try to update this category and
change the display order to 5.
you can see it is not actually updating
it is creating a new record with the
updated entities
and why is that
i want you guys to pause the video and
analyze on why this is happening
you guys were able to figure out the
reason edit is not working but it is
rather creating a new object
let me show you how i debug to find out
what is the issue
let's try to edit this
change the display order to 6 here and
we will switch back to the application
where we have the edit.cshtml.cs
we will add a debugging point on the on
post
let's go back and hit the update button
this time let me examine the category
and you will notice that id is 0.
now if you pass an object to update with
an id of 0 entity framework core will
think that this is a new object i need
to create that
because of that it is creating a new
category rather than updating
but the main question here is why is id
0
now the reason id is 0 is inside
edit.cshtml we have finded the category
name and display order but we have not
binded the id
so that's why there is no id field right
here
so if you want to do that you can have
an input field which is hidden
and we will use the asp4 tag helper this
will go to category.id
with that hidden field when the form is
posted it will have the id populated
let's hit continue here
we get this error we'll have to stop and
restart the application
and let me also remove the debugging
point
let's go back and try to edit any of the
category now
so we have this five we will try to edit
that
and change that to sex and perfect this
time it did not create a new category
so these are very small things that you
have to debug in the application
best way is to add a debugging point and
analyze what is the value
that will give you the exact idea of why
that is not working
so with that our edit functionality is
also working as expected
now for your assignment i want you to
implement the delete functionality
when you hit delete it should open up
the same page as edit it should say
delete category and this field should
not be editable so they should be
disabled
and you will have the delete button here
but before you do that i want to add a
button here to go back to the category
list
also inside create let me add that
button
so let me go back to the project
we will open up the create
we will add an anchor tag with asp page
of index some bootstrap classes and
within the anchor tag we will have back
to list
let me also copy this and we will paste
that
inside edit
let me save them go back and refresh
and perfect we have back to west that is
working as expected
now here we just wrote the page of index
so what happens is within the same
directory it will try to find the page
with the name of index we already have
that so it automatically takes us back
there
but you might be thinking that what if i
want to redirect to some other page
let's say we want to redirect to this
index page which is the root page of the
application
that is super simple before index you
will add double dot and forward slash so
then it will take you back to one level
and inside that folder it will try to
find the index page
let me show that we will save this
inside edit let's go there
back to list we get back to the home
page and not the category list page
we will roll back bring things back to
normal
perfect
if you have to route to some other
folder inside pages how to navigate
there
so perfect now in the next video you
have to implement the delete
functionality of deleting a category
so good luck with that and i'll show you
that in the next video
you guys were able to implement the
delete functionality
we will switch back to our application
first we will open up the index page
here and we need to pass the id to our
delete
so we will paste that here
and then we can stop the application
copy what we have for edit and paste it
one more time
we will rename that to delete
and we need to change the page model
make sure you're working on delete here
we'll change this to delete model
copy that
go back to the cs html and we will
rename there as well
now when we are deleting on get we will
have to find the category that we have
to delete
but inside post we can do something
different
we will have the id that will be
populated inside the category so we will
have to find the category object from
database we do not need this if
condition if the model state is valid we
can create a variable category from db
is equal
to underscore db dot category dot find
find that based on category dot id
so that will find the complete category
object and populate it right here
next we can check here if category from
db is not now
in that case we will say underscore db
dot category and we have the remove
method which expects a category entity
it does not expect an id it expects a
category entity so we will pass category
from db to be deleted
we will remove this and we will paste
the save async inside the if condition
if the model state is valid we redirect
back to index else we go back to the
page
so the page model looks good let's make
changes to the view
this will be delete category
everything will be disabled we do not
need validations
let me add the disabled field
and we have the hidden id that looks
good i'll change this to danger
and
delete perfect
let's run the application and try this
out
let's go to our categories
and try to delete test and three
as soon as we try to delete we get this
validation
the validation summary we should remove
that but something is not right
the reason behind that is if we go back
it is returning back to the page
so the model state is not valid now
obviously the model state will not be
valid because it will not have the name
and display order since they are
disabled
so we do not want to add model state
there because we are just finding the id
based on that we are retrieving that
from database and deleting that
we will move the redirect inside the if
condition
with that we will have to restart our
project
model state does not get populated for
disabled field
so that is something that you should
keep in mind
let's delete and perfect you can see
delete is also working as expected
now with that create update and delete
are working for our category
let's continue in the next video
i want to display an alert on the index
page that shows that what functionality
has been done
and those alerts should go away if you
refresh the page
so they should not stay on the page once
they have been displayed
for such special functionality we have
something called a stamp data with dot
net core
temp data has one main feature
it remains for only one request and if
you refresh the page it goes away
so that will work perfectly when we have
to display alert notification
so let's see how we can add something to
our temp data
let's go back to the application
and let's work with create let's open up
the dot cs file
inside the onpost before we redirect
we want to set something in temp data
so we have temp data that we will write
here and we need a key name
you can call this anything that you want
i will call that success because that is
the success message
so inside the key of success we want to
store a string which is category created
successfully
we can copy the stamp data
and we can add that in delete as well
before we redirect we can say category
delete it successfully
inside edit before we redirect we can
say category updated successfully
so we are setting our temp data on
create edit and delete
now if you notice once we create them it
is redirecting to the index page in all
the places
inside delete also that goes to the
index page
so what we will do is on
index.cshtml
inside the view or the ui side we need
to retrieve that temp data and see if
there is any string value inside there
so right here on top of the page we will
use razer syntax and we'll have the if
statement we will say if temp data you
will have to use the exact key name if
you use something else it won't work
so if temp data of success is not now
what we want to do is an h2 tag i want
to display the value
so in order to get the value from temp
data it is pretty straightforward we
just write temp data success
let me save all of that and we will have
to restart our application
this time let's try to create a category
as soon as we create you see we get a
notification in h2 tag and if you
refresh the page that goes away
so that is perfect
this way it only stays there for one
request
if you delete a category you can see we
have our alert which is category deleted
successfully
so this is great news and everything is
working as expected
now rather than displaying a string on
top it's best if we use some fancy
javascript code
let's do that in the next video
right now we are just displaying an h2
tag
but we can add something fancy in our
project
and that is toaster.js notification
if you go to the toaster.js kit repo you
will have a demo where we can see how
toaster notifications look and these are
much fancy
if we go back to the github we have the
css and js files
let me copy the css
let's go back to our application
inside the underscore layout we will add
that at the top here
link rel is equal to stylesheet
and href we will paste the url
next what we have is the js
so let me copy the js file
and then js we do not want to include in
underscore layout here let me do that
directly in index.cshtml
where we have temp data
one way i showed you how to use script
is at the end we can use the script
section
another way is right here we can use the
script tag
and within here we will say type is
equal to text
javascript
and we can use some custom js right here
before that we just want to include a
script so we'll say script src is equal
to
let me paste the url
now when we are working with toaster at
the same place we will also need jquery
so if you go to underscore layout we
have jquery script right here that is
included with our project
we can go back to the index and paste
that right here
we will remove the h2 element here
and perfect let's clean this up
now within the script tag we want to
call toaster and on there we have method
of success
let me go back and show that
we will have the use at some place you
see we have toaster.success
we can copy that and paste it here and
inside the parameters we want to pass
the temp data
that should be done inside single quotes
now we need to access the razor code so
we will use the add sign temp data
of success
that in place let me save this
go back and let me refresh the
application
let's try to edit a category here
now we see the fancy toaster
notification
if we delete a category
everything is working as expected but
now we have a fancy notification
so similar to success you can also
implement an if block here
that will be for
error temp data
and if you set something inside error we
will display that
this will be error
so that way we can use toaster with our
project
we have added alerts to our project
and if we go back to the application
this is some code that is common for
alerts
if you want to display alerts in other
pages you will have to copy this code
every time
and what if in future you change
something here
then you will have to go to all the
files and update the same code
that is a bad approach and for that
particular scenarios we have partial
views
we can move this code inside a partial
view and then we can directly call that
partial view here
that way in future if you have to change
something you will only change that in
one places and wherever that partial
view is called you don't have to change
anything in those files
so for that we will stop the application
partial views we will always add inside
the shared folder we will right click
add new razer page
we will go with the razer page empty and
so far we have been selecting razer page
but that creates a page with a page
model
partial views do not have a page model
that you can see inside underscore
layout and the validation scripts
partial
so that will be a razer view racer view
does not have a page model
and naming of partial view i always do
with an underscore that way by taking a
look at the name itself i can say that
that is a partial view
name we want to give here is
notification
let's add this razer view
you can see there is no page model with
the partial views
now here it says for enabling mvc
projects just ignore that
we will be using this as a partial view
in the razer page and that is completely
normal
let's go back to our index and let me
cut the code for toaster go back to
notification
and we will paste it right here
we will save this then we will go back
to our index and we need to call our
partial view with the name of underscore
notification
now when you have to use notification in
some other page you will just have to
add this one line of code
and also in future when you have to
change something you will just change
that directly in partial view and you
don't have to make that change across
all the other files
let's run the project and make sure
everything is still working the same
let's go to our categories
and we have an error i believe there is
some spelling mistake
i forgot an i here let me save that
and refresh
let's try to delete this time
and perfect
since these are magic strings make sure
that the name is exactly the same or you
will run into the edit messages like we
saw
so this is great but what if in your
functionality you wanted this partial
view to be across all of the pages in
your application
if that is the requirement indeed then
it doesn't make sense to add this one
line in all the pages
the alternative for that is we can cut
that partial tag from here and add it
inside the underscore layout directly
because this is rendered in all the
pages
so here just before render body we can
paste the partial tag and run the
project
if we try the categories one more time
it should work as expected
perfect
but you should be careful with this
approach because you are adding a piece
of code that will be present in all the
pages of your application
if that is something that your
requirement demands then for sure go
ahead and do that but do not add a bulky
code here that is not used it will just
increase your application overhead
so with that all of our crud
functionalities are working as expected
now we have seen how we can add pages to
our application and how to modify
everything else so far
let me show you one more thing here let
me create a new folder inside pages and
call this category temp
in there if we right click add razor
pages
you can see we have options here to
directly create razer pages using entity
framework for all the crud operation
what exactly will this do let me show
that if you hit the add button
first thing that you have to do is you
have to select a model
it will create all the pages for grunt
operations which stands for create read
update and delete
so we have to select a model there and
we need to select the db context because
that way it can access the database and
modify everything for the correct
operations
once you add those two this won't be a
partial view we want to use our master
page underscore layout so we will set
that as blank
and let's add this
this will take a while to scaffold
everything and then it will add all the
pages inside the category temp folder
now that it's done if you expand that
you can see it has added pages for
create delete details edit and index
everything by itself
let's run the application and take a
look at them
in order to navigate there we have to do
the manual navigation so here the name
of the folder is category temp
we can write index but if we don't it
will find that by default
and great you can see there is the index
page and we had one category it is
automatically displaying that
we can create a new category here
that's working if we hit create new it
also has validations
we have go back here
we can edit the category
that's working
we can view the details
and we can delete the category
so all of the functionalities of a basic
grunt application are done for us
if we go with that route
but i did not want to go with that
because i wanted to teach you how to
write all of this on your own
but if you examine the code here it is
doing the same things that we have done
nothing fancy
so that's just something for you guys to
play around
let me remove that because i do not want
multiple code
so with that our project is done and in
the next video let me show you how we
can deploy this to azure
now the final task is to deploy our
application to azure
so for that you will have to create an
account on
portal.azure.com i already have an
account
if you are signing up for the first time
you will get 200 dollars of free credit
that you can use
the first thing that we have to do in
here is we need to create a sql server
and a database inside that
so we can create or search for sql
databases
and let's hit the add button
usually i like creating everything from
visual studio but sql server i like to
create here that way i can easily see
all the configuration
you will select the subscription that
you have and in there we can create a
resource group
i will call this resource group as
dotnet mastery underscore course
and then let's enter a database name we
will call that dotnet mastery underscore
db
we do not have a server so let's create
a server the server name will be unique
so i will use dotnet mastery server
and then we need an admin login
we cannot use admin here that won't work
so i will just use admin sql
for password you can use something
secure select your location
and hit ok
now next option is to we want to use
elastic pool
we will say no there and in the server
location that's not available so let me
select some other location
each us2
and let's hit ok
then you need to select the compute plus
storage we will select configure
database there and i will use the lowest
option which is basic here and that is 5
usd per month let's apply
i do not want to pay more for the
subscription so i'm going with the
lowest option
the redundancy backup that is perfectly
fine with me let me hit review plus
create
we will hit create here and it will take
a while to configure our database and
set everything up
and perfect our database has been
created if we click go to resource it
will take us to sql database
now one thing that you will have to do
is if you want to access this database
from your local sql server you will have
to select the set firewall settings and
add your client ip
that will enable your client ip and you
can access the database from sql server
let's hit the save button to add your
client id there
once that is done let's go back to sql
server and we need to connect to that
server so we will hit ok here
go back to the resource and we have
connection string
let me copy the server name here
go back and paste it and we will use sql
server authentication
we have admin sql
and the password
let's press connect
great we are able to connect to our sql
server
so with that in place let's continue
from the next video let me close the
other tabs here
now that we have created our database in
azure we can go back to visual studio
and let's publish our
application we will have to create an
app service plan and we will have to
publish
we can do that directly from visual
studio as well
so here we will right click on project
and select publish
we will be selecting azure and hit next
here and then for now we will be
publishing to windows app service let's
select next
then you will have to log in to the
account where you want to publish once
you sign in with the account you will
select the subscription name here on the
top and we will have to create an app
service instance
i will call that as abbey web so the
final website or rather the temporary
website will be
abbeyweb.azurewebsites.net
it is a free domain that is provided by
azure
so we have subscription name next is the
resource group
you can create a new resource group but
i already have one of dotnet mastery
underscore course that is what i will
use
resource group are basically tags that
you can add to combine things under one
umbrella nothing fancy just like a
folder structure
next we have the hosting plan by default
an s1 tier hosting plan is selected
but i want to use the free hosting plan
that azure provides so we will select
that and press ok
let's hit the create button to create
our app service
that creates our app service and we will
hit the finish button
the final step that we have is we need
to configure our sql database
so you can see in the service
dependencies we can hit configure here
and we can add an azure sql database
it is already displaying the database
that we created on our account so we
will select that and hit the next button
now the connection string name inside
our application if you remember inside
the connection strings that was default
connection
we just need to write our user id which
is admin sql and the password
once you do that it automatically
populates that in the connection string
then we do not want to save connection
strings in app settings or keyword right
now but we can just copy the connection
string
let me open up a notepad and paste it
there
let's go back and hit the finish button
now that we have the connection string
let me click on any one of the settings
that we have here
inside the database we need to paste the
connection string
so let's expand that
and our connection string is valid we
will just select the use this connection
string at runtime
then inside the entity framework
migration right now there are no
migrations that have been applied we
already have the migrations in the
folder so we can select apply this
migrations on publish and that will
create the tables inside the database
now right now we are working with dotnet
6 and it is not available in the app
service
so for that we will change the
deployment mode to self-contained and
that should work
with that change let me save this and
publish our application
you can see the site name i said before
will be abbeyweb.azurewebsites.net
and this is a free subdomain that is
provided by azure
it is retrying the add operation but
that is failing
inside the logs here you can see we have
issue with the client ip
let me copy this error paste that in
notepad
i believe we added the ip we will copy
this go back to azure in overview set
firewall
we will add a new client ip
let's save that
that is the ip from the server
with that change let me publish it one
more time and it should work
once the deployment is complete it will
automatically
load the website url in a browser
it is loading our website let's take a
look
and create you can see everything is
working there will be a new categories
table
with no category right now
we can add categories
we have our alerts and we can edit
update and delete
so everything is working as expected and
our website is live on azure
congratulations on completing the course
with this course you have a basic
foundation on razer pages and how to
perform grud operations using entity
framework core
this is just getting started with razer
pages in.net core
there are many more topics that i cover
in my advanced course
let me just give you some highlights of
the topics that i cover in that course
the project that we have built so far we
will divide that project in an anterior
architecture where we will have a
separate data access layer
in that data access layer we will be
using repository pattern and unit of
word to access our database
we have already seen temp data in action
so we will use that and we will see how
we can add api controllers with our
razer pages project
that way we can use the apis that we
build in data tables and we will see
suite alerts as well as rich text editor
these are just some basic
functionalities in a typical application
also in any real world application we
have authentication and authorization
so for that we will scaffold the
built-in identity razor class library
that the dotnet team provides
with authentication using identity class
library we will also see roles and
authorization in action
once we add authentication and
authorization to our project then we
will use stripe for payment collection
and we will also see how to issue
refunds using stripe apis
we also have sessions in.net core so we
will see how to configure our
application and send emails using smtp
and sendgrid
i will also show how to use facebook for
social login
we also have some advanced concepts like
view component and how to see database
with the initial data using a db
initializer class
once we cover all of these advanced
topics we will deploy our application to
azure and we will see how everything
comes together
so this will be a pretty lengthy course
and we will go into building a real
world project with real requirements
so if you want you can check out this
course and other courses on.net mastery
and if you like this video please like
and subscribe to the channel
so i hope to see you guys in some other
course
till then happy coding